all right chances are you stumbled upon
this video because you're trying to
unscramble this mess that you have in
front of you well I'm gonna try to make
a how-to on the 3x3 which is the regular
Rubik's Cube and I'm gonna try to make
it for beginners so let's get started
what you want to first notice is that
the cube has six sides which is pretty
obvious but you have to also realize
that it has six centers which have six
different colors and each of these
colors that you see on each of these
centers that makes each side what color
the center is so this is the orange side
this is the blue side yellow side etc
and this is going to be the white side
the way that I hold it I hold it with
the yellow side on top and the white
side on the bottom and what I first try
to figure out or try to solve is the
white side okay so I also have to
explain that sometimes if I denote
things as front or back or bottom it
depends on how you're holding it if I'm
holding it like this this will be the
front this would be the back this would
be the up face as I call it this would
be the down face this would be the left
and the right if I turned it this way
this would this would be the front face
now this is the back and so forth so the
first thing that you want to do is you
want to place four white edge pieces
around the yellow center now these are
the edge pieces on all side all sides
have edge pieces and these are the
corner pieces edge pieces basically have
two colors and corner pieces have three
colors there is also a center piece on
each side which only has one color and
the center piece is what denotes what
color the side will be that you are
looking at so this is going to be the
yellow side as I said before blue side
and etc okay so the first thing you
do is you want to place those four white
edge pieces around the yellow Center in
these positions now it doesn't matter
this is you it could be in any position
as far as what's there already because I
know I mean you mix it up and you have
these four positions here so what you
want to do first is you want to look
around the cube in the middle layer for
white edge pieces and the reason you
want to look here is because this is the
place where you could flip it directly
up next to this yellow Center so that
would be one edge piece that's in place
now so you'd look again around in the
middle layer for another edge piece
here's another one now don't pay
attention to this corner white piece it
doesn't that has no influence on the
edge piece as far as what we're trying
to do here so you can pop this one up
right here now if this piece is in the
way over here you don't want to flip it
up while that's there you want to have
an empty spot here that has that does
not have a white piece in it a white
edge piece so now you can flip that up
look again in this case we have another
one that we can just flip right up to
this empty spot now the last one is
tricky this is the only open space that
we have on the top to place that last
white edge piece and in this case it is
directly in front of this empty spot so
we can flip it directly up but sometimes
it's not sometimes it can be on the
bottom here and in that case what you
need to do is you need to get it into
the middle layer so that you could snap
it up so let's say it was over here one
thing that you could do is you can get
it in the in the in the the middle layer
by turning this face clockwise then what
you'd notice is that you just kick that
one out of its position you kick this
white edge piece out of the position so
once you do that you have to flip this
here and then you have to put this white
edge piece back so that's one case
another case could be it's down here
somewhere now what you want to do in
this case you can't turn this and put it
in these positions because it's occupied
so what you do is you could turn it here
so that it's directly beneath this one
and as before you turn it so that you
can get it in that empty spot and then
you have to put this one back okay so
now we have the four white edge pieces
in place and you don't have to play
around with that because there are some
situations where it it looks a little
bit different than when I explain but
that's basically it for the most part
okay
so what you want to do now is you want
to notice that these four white edge
pieces have colors on the other side on
this others the adjacent side of the
piece so this one is the white red piece
this is white orange this is white green
and this is the white blue piece what
you want to do is you want to match up
those colors with their respective
centers what I mean by that is if you'll
look here this one has already matched
up with its Center the white orange
piece is matched up with the orange
Center so once you match it up with the
orange Center if it wasn't matched up
say it was over here you turn it like
that now it's matched up once you match
it up like that you want to match the
white piece the white color with its
white Center and by in order to do that
once you match it up to the orange you
take it and you flip it 180 degrees
upside down
now it's matched up with both the white
and the orange centers so you have to do
that for the remaining three okay so we
have the white red you match it with the
red and you turn it 180 degrees upside
down until the white is matched with the
white we'll do that for the other one
then the blue is already matched now so
we just turn it 180 degrees upside down
you should see
to the ones that you matched up you
should see them stay together you should
not be turning this top layer at all so
you turn this directly upside down now
that's three and the remaining one is
the the green and the green Center is
over here so we turn it until the Greens
matched then we turn this upside down
now what you see on the bottom is a
cross it's a white cross and you should
see each of these white edge pieces that
we had on top they should be matched to
both the color in the center and also to
the white that's step one